hi my name is vineeth Meyer I'm the CEO
of digital technologies I had put out a
question on my way to the World Economic
Forum Davos on your vision on new models
of transformation which the world should
adopt across Twitter Facebook and my
blog
we got about 300 very interesting
responses and so as I had done in the
past all these responses added a new
dimension Who am I thinking which I
converted into a blog which I wrote for
Fortune in us and dance of India in
India interestingly as you crowdsource
ideas what has come out very clearly is
there are multiple dimensions of
thinking of the same problem each one of
us looks at the problem from different
sides but interestingly the genoise
which is the large participation we saw
in in today's created Facebook were
approaching the whole whole problem from
a solution intention one step at a time
it was a very difficult job for us to
look at all the responses and judge them
because each one of them were good in
their own rights however I took the help
of my colleagues and looked at the
practicality of the ideas the uniqueness
of the ideas the implement ability of
the ideas and saying if we can try and
rate them and here is the list of things
which we really really like and the
winners on the Facebook is hung kids
Ashok other wall from India a join
lowkick from Philippines
Claudia slow-burning from Belgium
Jane Laos McDonnell Manchester on the
Twitter we saw Rajesh to crawl currency
Steve patrasche Dogra and David Lapine
when the pub for our prizes we also put
this question on the LCL meme site which
the internal side for it's here and the
winners there is Chandra Shekar Singh
from Bangalore rather Krishnan Malu from
Hyderabad
super honker British Aria from us couple
Matra from Noida and
Buddha Subramanyam from Chennai so thank
you so much for your participation I
really got enriched by your ideas and
keep helping shaping the world with your
ideas thank you